hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge gautschi
mir leid ich weiß nicht wieso ich so
redet wie ein kommandant gibt's das wort
kommandant wir klicken auf spiel und
nehmen wieder die gleiche karte denn wir
haben heute eine mission bei der lieben
freunde wenn ihr die letzte folge wird
nicht gesehen ob verlinkt ich euch die
hier und zwar schon da mal rein denn
dort haben wir einen komischen platz in
den bergen entdeckt und da wurde mit
relativ häufig in die kommentare
geschrieben dass sich fünf personen
dorthin bringen muss und dann können wir
zu verschiedenen l
warum passiert mir das immer wir sollen
auf jeden fall fünf leute dorthin
bringen und als opfergaben dort da dran
packen
ich bin nicht gemacht für dieses spiel
und dann können wir irgendwie zu aliens
gehen aber schaut euch jetzt erstmals
ein laufband das war spaß sich aus das
heißt wir suchen uns jetzt erstmal ein
paar menschen die wir dorthin packen
können nämlich erstmal in ihr von hinten
an griechenland mail.com mit kleiner
mann wir werden zusammen zu dem tollen
platz da hinten gehen also wenn ihr
gesehen war wie wir den weg da möchte
ich euch die letzte folge sonst laufen
wir jetzt gerade hin
die sind wir denn noch mal dahin
gekommen genau hierhin hoch und jetzt
platziere ich bin vorne so die opfer
sammeln dass dinos gold ich blicke den
mal da vorne hin weil ich glaube wir
müssen die auf diese verschiedenen
sachen drauf legen genau du bleibst da
liegen ich wohl ebenfalls andere wir
gehen einfach hier hinten wieder zu
meinen freunden zu der grillparty wollte
mir vielleicht auch was drin
unter den hier nämlich noch mal eben mit
dem bringen wir dann auch irgendwann
habe ich ihm verlobt was macht ihr da
ein du ich möchte ja echt nicht weh tun
aber ich brauche dich mal eben ganz
konzentriert
unter folter was ist mit diesem typen
ich will dich einfach da hinten zur
opfergabe bringen wir laufen heißt
einfach mal in der wird schon irgendwie
mit kommen oder soll kommen hier den
berg instaload gewechselt sondern sind
wir jetzt wo ist er ja du denkst du
kommt verwundert aber nein du kommst mir
zum apfalter dich platziere ich hier
vorne eben auf der 5 so achte sind
zahlen jedoch nicht
zwei opfer von 5 haben wir schon an dem
wir jetzt mal eben wieder zu der freunde
die ich hier vorne nämlich auch noch mal
eben schnell mit dem richter ganz schön
hin weil das wird heute extra art
experiment das heißt wenn ihr sehen
wollt wie aliens oder so hierhin kommen
oder uns oder er war damit will ich auf
jeden fall perfekt er legt sich direkt
schon richtig dahin und wollen
daumen hoch geben auf die werbung
klicken nur aus was sie zu sagen denn
hier vorne im blauen kostüm schmeißt
sich auch noch eben stellen auf die
opfergabe und dann sind wir eigentlich
auch erstmal ein bisschen aus dann sind
wir jetzt auch endlich mal unterwegs
nach den sechseinhalb stunden pause hier
und dich platziere ich genau hier nein
du gehst nicht dahin du kommst schön
hier hin genau da vorne geht schon
wieder eine party die das party monster
schlechthin kommt natürlich auch mit
opel vom opfer alter damit wir da auch
ein bisschen die weibliche bereitschaft
mit amstutz haben brauchen ist die
wieder
irgendwo hängen geblieben hier was ist
denn das du bist weg gelaufen oder was
ist denn das für ein scheiß ihr dürft
nicht weglaufen ihr bleibt hier liegen
alt hamborn dort meine opfergabe brennt
und was war das kann ich da mal eben das
logo von
kommen dann neben behalten brennen der
opfergabe mit alter das juckt mich auch
nicht ich muss irgendwie fünf leute
zusammenkriegen ohne dass wieder vorne
die ganze zeit wieder weglaufen man was
ist denn das sie für ein chaos bleibt
doch einfach hier läuft schon wieder
einer weg alter ich hätte nie gedacht
dass es so schwer ist einfach fünf leute
an einem stück zusammen zu kriegen aber
die leute sind einfach dumm ich hab
gesagt du sollst dableiben und du läufst
einfach fällt dann bist du selbst schuld
vielleicht sollte ich mit anderen weise
daran gehen ich hatte dich so lieb ich
dich küssen scheint nicht so überzeugt
davon zu sein freunde das ist jetzt die
fünfte opfer gabe die wir da oben hin
bringen das heißt laut euren kommentaren
sollten dann aliens kommen oh mein gott
was passiert hier was passiert hier was
passiert hier was habe ich getan ich
kann anscheinend eher drücken
was habe ich getan als er ich kann alle
menschen in diese dämonische macht mit
rein saugen was habe ich getan
mein gott was habe ich getan
was habe ich getan um mein gott was
ich will ein monster was in gottes namen
habe ich an dieser ziege alter das ist
nicht wahr ich kann die ich habe keine
erklärung für dieses spiel das ist
einfach nur total krank
wo sind wir
wir sind außerhalb von der welt ist das
eine raumstation oder hören ich drücke
jetzt mal einfach wieder
back to the roots patches ich würde
sagen nach dieser mega kassen folge was
haben wir getan wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen wenn ihr noch mehr tricks für
dieses spiel hab irgendwie sowas wie
fünf leute da drauf packen wird diese
dämonische züge schreibt mir dass unsere
kommentare macht es mega viel spaß und
dieses spiel ist einfach krank
es ist einfach crazy ich gehe mit dieser
ziegel jetzt noch ein bisschen gassi und
dann wünsche ich euch auf jeden fall
noch einen schönen tag